Jim Parsons big star the Big Bang Theory
and he is leading the celebrity bracket
challenged he had his birthday yesterday
man everything is going well for you
good to have you back Jim I'm glad you
finally caught a break
I've missed you more than I can I
literally had to quit my television show
in order to make time is that the reason
why we're ending the Big Bang sir one of
the major reasons yes have you are
important things in life to get it on
and so you make time for them you make
your choices have you filmed the final
episode nope we're down to our final
four we start we start that this week
and then yeah then we'll have 270
something in the books I don't know take
us back to that first episode if I were
to talked to you when you got home from
the first episode what would you have
said the shooting in that vision well I
thought it went well I knew that I
thought it went well but I didn't I mean
you know how it is to be putting out a
product for wide public consumption
there's really no telling all you can do
is what you think is OK and and so I
felt like you know there are plenty of
good TV shows that have gone to the
ditch as it were and and so I just I
just had no idea if anybody would
actually care about this and and I
wasn't a fair judge of it you can't
judge what you're doing very well when
you're in the thick of it but yeah I
don't know it's it's a it's a weird
feeling to look back on that now you
know 12 years is a is a long time that's
the biggest thing I'm finding is that I
feel like I'm a very not a very
different person but like oh my god your
mind just works differently after over a
decade of time going by you know do you
remember the first time you felt famous
I remember I remember the first few
times I started getting stopped by
strangers and that what that I
found a little odd I don't know because
I was already in my early 30s by then so
I don't know if I was just old enough to
be like I've never experienced world
like this and so maybe if I was younger
which I don't know that that doesn't
always work out obviously but if you are
younger maybe it's like I'm sure this is
the new way things are gonna be but I
was you know I was a thirty year old man
or above by then and I just kind of was
like this is this is going to take some
getting used to and that part still
takes some getting used to for me it
does you know I still there's part of me
that enters oh god a shopping mall or
anything like that where you're where
you feel like you're just gonna treat it
like you always did and and I still have
a completely reprogrammed for that yet
oddest place you've been recognized Oh
God
well the bathrooms always weird I feel
like anybody I'm sure all of you events
those were urinal experience yeah this
is not the time to talk about this but
no handshaking
no but I've taken one all right just so
bad saying and instantaneous no my go-to
I don't know it's because I was raising
the sounds like oh sure we're talking to
Jim Parsons The Big Bang Theory start
did you you did you channel Sheldon and
filling out your brackets or or is this
just a boy this is embarrassing
I have rarely filled out my bracket with
lesson but I'm never real informed on
college basketball's it is I find it
overwhelming to try and pretend to keep
up throughout the season and leading up
to this but normally I've got some sort
of vague notion and and the other thing
I used to do and this is how I came to
this year's brilliant picks I used to
Google whatever Obama was picking and
looks from there because I always
figured well he's got the smartest
people working for him you know so a
bunch of MIT grads picking these picks
it sounds wonderful and it worked out
okay although I never won well this year
his weren't published or I couldn't find
them but I found who was it was somebody
on Yahoo I think Henry Bushnell does
that ring a bell to you know
okay well see and he had ranked in some
article like who had the best chances
just going on down like a numbered list
well that's good and so I started going
down I was like whoever he says that
number one I'm gonna take him to the
final whoever he says never gentlemen it
going they're gonna be the competitor
and and I did that for about
three-quarters of the bracket and I
thought well this is getting really
boring and so the thing I haven't picked
up to that point I just like I didn't
upset I did the lower seat for each one
that's the science behind my bracket
busting leaving I don't even know what
you call it how much am i leading by I
can't even figure this out I've been
traveling it so I have not seen a single
game and I haven't even shaved my
bracket
McLovin can you give Jim an update yeah
you're up by five points so you have 59
points and next-closest Kevin Frazier 54
there's a lot yeah that's big now would
you rather win another Emmy win the
celebrity bracket challenge well I do
feel that winning a celebrity bracket
thing would be a profound feeling
nothing Emmy isn't but you know you've
got a few of those I've got some of
those and this is this is about as close
to a sporting title as I could ever get
what if I make a trophy if you win don't
say it's not so
oh my god its trophy you don't give out
trophies normally no what a crock I have
no idea there was no hardware at all
there's not even like a certificate uh
it's respect you can't paint I don't
remember doing any of the last
challenges we've done no you're right
about that I don't remember it is that I
know maybe that's just me maybe that's
just me I didn't mean to come on to be
so negative about it I'm enjoying this
and I'm loving leading the pack are you
gonna retire from TV I don't think so no
I don't know what I'm gonna do I'm gonna
keep working I know that but I really
don't know what's next and and things
like that it's a very fun
I'll be honest about it not necessarily
unpleasant at this point while I'm still
working but I don't think it'll be I
don't think too much time will go by
once we got that last episode like what
am i doing what do we not know about
doing a weekly show like what is the no
oh god I think it's both a lot easier
and a lot harder than it seems I mean
like I mean over our show at least
there's there's a real the machine
really works well and always has it are
it are at our show I mean we had a lot
of people involved that from the top
down that were had done a lot of shows
so we had a lot of experience that we
came into this with and that and that
shows but there's also much more by the
skin of your teeth sort of stuff with
this where it's like well this just what
it seemed gonna get funny and then they
then they come in and fiddle with it and
suddenly suddenly it's working and we
have taped episodes and I don't I mean I
don't I mean this is a compliment but I
that I've thought not our best work and
then I've seen them played back or on
the air and I'm like well that's not bad
at all so I don't know I don't I think
there's a lot of I mean there are a lot
of cooks in the kitchen but you know I
think about a show like yours all the
time with ours in comparison it's like
we do we do 24 minutes of programming
and we take five days to do it you do
three hours and you do it every day and
you're committed in some ways all of you
I I think I asked you for this a while
ago but maybe you forgot you want
did I forget but did I well I used what
is I said and you graciously sent us a
signed copy of the I think 103 episode
what do you really want I wanted
want to Sheldon shirts that sign so I
can frame it okay like I show you
sure you know we only have four shows
left they've got to be assured that
they're done using yeah I am NOT tearing
through that wardrobe in the final 120
minutes or whatever it is this is not
happening
but but you you have people who can do
this all they have to do I do
yeah I mean of course I think they'd be
thrilled well not everybody but I think
a lot of some people they wouldn't be
thrilled there's some people's like what
the hell you're talking about but there
are people in that set that we've
thrilled to know the dance I said hey do
you guys have one question you want to
ask Jim Parsons like what would it be
and they the consensus was how much are
you bench pressing now oh well I'm in a
rental because we sold our house in LA
and so I don't have my normal equipment
with me in the gym hmm and and and I
broke my foot over the summer and so I
kind of got you're not using your flick
to benchpress their athletes ooh no
you're right you don't you don't but but
when you're a drama queen like I travel
up and it impacts every limb on your
body and suddenly you're weak everywhere
you really can barely even think so I've
only recently gotten back there in the
past couple of months and I am doing
this is not good but I'm using the
heaviest thing we have here or 240 pound
freeways and so I was your best Oh Jim
what's your best I really don't know
numbers don't matter
no yeah they do when it comes to bench
pressing I know they do is you know what
here's what here I go I'm gonna move
we're gonna go back to New York after
these four episodes are up which will do
two things for me that I am really
looking forward to one is make me more
available should you ever want to see me
in person again to come visit you and
the second is I will be back with my
trainer there and and I'll start keeping
a chart if that will make you happy if
that's what we need to go forward in our
relationship I can manage this oh wait I
have a quick question for you what I
didn't realize you've had cats you have
three cats
yeah and a dog is that bad the dog no I
thought your attitude towards the cats
was bad and this may have been something
that I just I don't I've forgotten
but how old are your cats you want them
to die no no but they're gonna outlive
me like you no no no no no they're gonna
outlive me
you know the cats are there cats are
great they are and and you'll never get
it right no no no I don't I don't want
em how many cats is too many well for me
even I'm allergic
yeah yeah so I got three dogs I did our
two dogs one just died and then I have
three cats and you know so you know it's
it's great I'm dr. Dolittle man yeah I
am I'm feedom I'm there you know they
sit in my lap they you know that's
really sweet
yeah that's me yeah I think though if
you were gonna use a word for me and be
sweet and I appreciate that somewhere
good luck on the UH on the brackets and
more importantly the final four episodes
there and we hope to cross paths with
you in New York again oh you will all
right don't tell Todd we settle oh thank
you Jim family I that's Jim Parsons Big
Bang Theory Sheldon and doing some
big-time stuff there for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience channel 239
on Direct TV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]